E
EMERGENCY, WHICH IS A STEP MANY
DEMOCRATS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTIVISTS SAY IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED.
>> THIS IS AN EMERGENCY.
AN EMERGENCY.
AND I WILL LOOK AT IT THAT WAY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN TAKING NEW
STEPS TODAY TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS.
TURNING TO HIS EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY AFTER CONGRESS STYMIED
HIS FAR MORE AMBITIOUS PLANS TO
TRY TO COMBAT GLOBAL WARMING.
>> I'LL SAY IT AGAIN LOUD AND
CLEAR.
AS PRESIDENT I'LL USE MY
EXECUTIVE POWERS TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CRISIS IN THE ABSENCE OF
CONGRESSIONAL ACTION.
>> STANDING BENEATH THE
BLISTERING SUN, THE PRESIDENT
STOPPED SHORT OF DECLARING A
NATIONAL CLIMATE EMERGENCY.
FOR NOW AT LEAST.
AS HE VISITED A MASSACHUSETTS
PLANT THAT HELPS CONNECT
OFFSHORE WIND FARMS TO THE POWER
GRID.
THE PLANT STANDS OUTSIDE THE
TOWN OF SOMERSET, ONCE THE
LARGEST COAL POWERED ELECTRICITY
PLANT IN THE NORTHEAST, BUT NOW
MAKES POWER CABLES ESSENTIAL TO
CAPTURING THE WIND ENERGY.
>> I HAVE BEEN SAYING THIS THREE
YEARS.
I THINK JOBS.
CLIMATE CHANGE, I THINK JOBS.
>> THE PRESIDENT VOISED HIS
FRUSTRATION AT CONGRESS WITHOUT
SPECIFICALLY MENTIONING SENATOR
JOE MANCHIN OF WEST VIRGINIA,
WHO EFFECTIVELY TORPEDOED
BROADER LEGISLATION.
PART OF THE BUILD BACK BETTER
ECONOMIC AGENDA, CITING CONCERNS
OF RISING INFLATION.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS TODAY'S
EXECUTIVE ACTIONS WOULD CREATE A
WIND ENERGY AREA IN THE GULF OF
MEXICO, COVERING 700,000 ACRES
WITH POTENTIAL TO POWER MORE
THAN 3 MILLION HOMES.
AND TARGET 2.3 BILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING FOR COMMUNITIES MOST
AFFECTED BY THE SCORCHING HEAT,
INCLUDING PROVIDING COOLING
CENTERS AND AIR CONDITIONING TO
LOW-INCOME AMERICANS.
THESE MODEST STEPS ARE THE FIRST
OF MANY, OFFICIALS SAID, AS
BIDEN SEEKS TO TAKE THE REINS OF
THE CLIMATE KRIES IN HOPES OF
SHOWING THE WORLD THE U.S. IS
STILL SERIOUS ABOUT MEETING ITS
GOALS.
>> CLIMATE CHANGE IS AN
EMERGENCY, AND IN THE COMING
WEEKS I'M GOING TO USE THE POWER
I HAVE AS PRESIDENT TO TURN
THESE WORDS INTO FORMAL OFFICIAL
GOVERNMENT ACTIONS THROUGH THE
APPROPRIATE PROCLAMATIONS AND
EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND REGULATORY
POWER THAT A PRESIDENT
POSSESSES.
>> SO THE PRESIDENT THERE JUST
WALKING RIGHT UP TO THE EDGE OF
THAT NATIONAL CLIMATE EMERGENCY.
YOU MAY ASK, WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE?
IS IT SIMPLY SEMANTICS OR MORE?
IT ACTUALLY IS MORE.
DECLARING A FORMER EMERGENCY
WOULD OPEN THE DOOR TO MORE
FUNDING AND ESSENTIALLY CLEAR
AWAY SOME OF THE BUREAUCRATIC
RED TAPE AND ALLOW THE WHITE
HOUSE TO DO MUCH MORE ADDRESSING
CLIMATE.
IT WOULD ALSO SEND A SIGNAL TO
THE REST OF THE WORLD THAT THE
U.S. IS STILL FOCUSED ON CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS, OF COURSE,
AFTER THE LACK OF ACTION IN
CONGRESS.
SO CLEARLY, THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYING THIS IS THE FIRST STEP OF
MANY.
THE QUESTION IS, WILL ANYTHING
IN CONGRESS EVER MOVE?
WE'RE NOW THREE AND A HALF
MONTHS BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
>> JEFF ZELENY IN MASSACHUSETTS,
THANKS.
LET'S BRING IN FORMER OBAMA
SENIOR ADVISER, DAVID AXELROD.
THESE EXECUTIVE ACTIONS FALL
SHORT OF THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
THAT SENATE DEMOCRATS WERE
HOPING TO GET PASSED.
SENATOR JEFF MERKLEY OF OREGON
TWEETED THIS.
INACTION ISN'T AN OPTION.
CLIMATE CHAOS IS AN EMERGENCY
AND THE PRESIDENT SHOULD DECLARE
A NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND PURSUE
BOLD CLIMATE ACTION.
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE SEEN THIS
MOVIE BEFORE.
THE PRESIDENT, WE'RE TOLD THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO DO
SOMETHING AND IT MIGHT EVEN BE
SUPER BOLD STEP A, AND THEN HE
DOESN'T DO SUPER BOLD STEP A,
AND HE ENDS UP LOOKING CAUTIOUS.
I SIT HERE THINKING, WHY IS
THIS -- THIS WHITE HOUSE DOES
SEEM KIND OF CAUTIOUS.
>> WELL, I THINK IT REFLECTS
HIM.
HE IS AN INSTITUTIONALIST, AND
HE DOESN'T MOVE, YOU KNOW,
PRECIPITOUSLY.
THAT IS HIS NATURE.
I THINK THEY DO CREATE A PROBLEM
FOR THEMSELVES, THOUGH, THE
EXPECTATIONS GAME HAS BEEN ONE
THAT HAS TRIPPED THEM UP
THROUGHOUT.
INCLUDING FROM THE BEGINNING,
THIS NOTION THAT WITH A 50/50
SENATE AND A BARELY -- AND A
CLOSELY DIVIDED HOUSE, YOU WERE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO THINGS OF
ROOSEVELTIAN MAGNITUDE.
I THINK IT WAS PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE THE FACT IS HE'S GOTTEN
A LOT OF THINGS DONE.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WOULD
HAVE LOVED TO HAVE HAD THAT GUN
BILL THAT HE SIGNED.
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE HAD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT HE
SIGNED.
IF HE GETS THE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
NEGOTIATION POWER FOR MEDICARE,
THAT WAS SOMETHING DEMOCRATS HAD
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR 20 YEARS.
BUT EVERYTHING SEEMS SMALLER
BECAUSE THE EXPECTATIONS WERE
SET PERHAPS UNREALISTICALLY
HIGH.
THE SAME IS TRUE ON SOME OF
THESE EXECUTIVE ACTIONS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT HIS
REASONING IS BEHIND NOT
DECLARING AN EMERGENCY NOW.
I WOULD ONLY SAY IF HE'S GOING
TO DO IT, GET THERE QUICKLY.
DON'T DITHER.
DO IT.
>> BUT IT'S LIKE, THE ENTIRE
WORLD IS ON FIRE RIGHT NOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE -- IF YOU ACTUALLY
THINK IT IS A CLIMATE EMERGENCY,
AND HIS LANGUAGE SUGGESTS THAT
HE DOES THINK THAT, WHY WOULDN'T
HE?
>> I'M SURE THERE ARE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS WITHIN THE WHITE
HOUSE ABOUT WHAT THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF EACH STEP WOULD
BE.
BUT AGAIN, DON'T GET PUSHED
THERE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO GO THERE, GO
AND MAKE THAT ANNOUNCEMENT
QUICKLY.
>> SO PRESIDENT BIDEN'S JOB
APPROVAL RATING IS AT 38%.
ACCORDING TO CNN'S RECENT POLL
WITH THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
APPROACHING.
THAT'S PRETTY LOW.
ONE THING THAT'S VERY
INTERESTING IS THAT BIDEN HAS
THESE HORRIBLE APPROVAL RATINGS.
AND YET THE GENERIC BALLOT,
WOULD YOU RATHER VOTE FOR A
DEMOCRAT OR A REPUBLICAN IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS COMING UP, IS
PRETTY DIVIDED.
>> YES.
>> AND IN FACT, DEMOCRATS WERE
BEHIND IN MAY.
>> DEMOCRATS MADE SOME PROGRESS.
>> NOW IT'S EVEN.
HOT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> IT'S SORT OF UNPRECEDENTSED.
THERE'S BEEN A CLOSE LINK
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL
RATING AND THE PERFORMANCE OF
THE PARTY IN MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
WHAT I MAKE OF IT IS THAT THIS
DECISION, THE DOBBS DECISION OF
THE COURT --
>> OVERTURNING ROE V. WADE.
>> OVERTURNING ROE V. WADE, THE
MASS SHOOTINGS THAT WE SAW, THE
ELECTION DENIALISM, THE
VICTORIES IN PRIMARIES SUCH AS
THE ONE IN MARYLAND YESTERDAY OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE RATHER EXTREME
POSITIONS ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE
ON THESE, HAVE ALL CREATED SOME
DOUBT AMONG INDEPENDENT VOTERS
IN PARTICULAR, ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
SIX MONTHS AGO, JAKE,
INDEPENDENT VOTERS WERE SAYING,
GEE, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
TACKING TOO FAR LEFT.
I THINK THEY'RE OUT OF TOUCH.
AND SO ON.
NOW I THINK THAT DISCUSSION IS
TOUCHING THE REPUBLICANS BECAUSE
OF ALL OF THIS.
AND THAT IS THE HOPE.
THE HOPE FOR DEMOCRATS WITH ALL
OF THIS ATMOSPHERE WORKING
AGAINST THEM, INFLATION, SUPPLY
CHAIN, EVERYTHING WORKING
AGAINST THEM, THE HOPE FOR
DEMOCRATS IS REPUBLICANS.
AND TRUMP, AND THE NOTION THAT
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS BECOME
TOO EXTREME.
>> SO FORMER JEB BUSH ADVISER
TIM MILLER HAS BEEN RECOMMENDING
FOR ABOUT A YEAR, HE'S VERY
ANTI-TRUMP, THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD
BE USING WEDGE ISSUES AGAINST
REPUBLICANS THE WAY THAT
REPUBLICANS GENERALLY
EFFECTIVELY DO WHEN THEY CONTROL
THE HOUSE AND SENATE AGAINST
DEMOCRATS.
AN EXAMPLE, KING YESTERDAY
MILLER SAID WHEN DEMOCRATS ACTED
IN THE HOUSE TO CODIFY, MAKE THE
LAW OF THE LAND THE SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE LEGALIZATION.
WHICH TED CRUZ AND OTHERS HAVE
SAID THEY THINK THAT SUPREME
COURT DECISION SHOULD BE
OVERTURNED AS WELL.
47 REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE
VOTED FOR IT, WHICH IS A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS, EVEN THOUGH
OBVIOUSLY MORE VOTED AGAINST IT,
157 REPUBLICANS VOTED AGAINST
IT.
NOW, THE U.S. SENATE, THEY'RE
TRYING TO SEE IF THERE'S ENOUGH
SENATE REPUBLICANS TO VOTE FOR
IT.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S AN EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY?
>> I DO, I THINK AGAIN, FOR
DEMOCRATS, PAINTING THE PORTRAIT
OF A REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT HAS
GONE WAY OFF TO THE RIGHT, AND
THAT IS SO CONSUMED BY THOSE
ISSUES THAT THEY'RE NOT REALLY
FOCUSED ON INFLATION AND THE DAY
TO DAY ISSUES THAT ARE TOUCHING
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
I THINK THAT'S THE BEST ARGUMENT
THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE GOING INTO
THE FALL.
I THINK THEY SHOULD CAMPAIGN ON
SOME OF THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN BELITTLED THAT ARE
REALLY QUITE IMPORTANT OF
BIDEN'S, BUT IT'S REALLY ABOUT
MAKING THIS A CHOICE.
THAT'S THE CHOICE THAT THEY HAVE
TO PAINT.
SO YES, I DO AGREE WITH THAT.
THE INTERESTING STRATEGIC
QUESTION FOR SCHUMER IS, IF YOU
PUT IT ON THE FLOOR, DOES IT
GIVE SOME REPUBLICANS A CHANCE
TO GET WELL?
DOES IT -- YOU REMEMBER MITCH
McCONNELL JOINED REPUBLICANS TO
VOTE FOR THE COMPROMISE GUN
BILL.
MY VIEW WAS HE DID THAT BECAUSE
HE UNDERSTOOD THE PARTY WAS
LOOKING, TACKING TOO FAR TO THE
RIGHT.
SUBURBAN VOTERS WERE BEGINNING
TO DRIFT.
HE WANTED TO SIGNIFY THAT THERE
WAS A MODERATE OR A MORE
MODERATE GROUP IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
AND THAT IS THE CASE HERE.
BUT ON THE MERITS, YOU KNOW, I
HOPE THEY DO VOTE ON IT.
>> THERE WAS A "NEW YORK TIMES"
POLL, I BELIEVE IT WAS LAST
WEEK, SHOWING MOST REPUBLICANS
DID NOT WANT TRUMP TO RUN.
MOST DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO RUN FOR
RE-ELECTION, AND THE NUMBER ONE
CONCERN WAS HIS AGE.
I THINK HE'S 79 RIGHT NOW.
>> HE'LL BE 80 IN DECEMBER.
>> AND HE IS THE OLDEST
PRESIDENT IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> LISTEN, I DO THINK THAT THAT
IS A CONCERN.
AND I THINK IT WOULD BE FOOLISH
NOT TO SAY IT'S NOT IF HE RAN
AGAIN, HE WOULD BE 82 WHEN HE
GOT ELECTED, CLOSER TO 90 THAN
80 AT THE END OF THAT -- AT THE
END OF THAT TERM.
I THINK THAT HE HAS A BODY OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT IS PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT, STARTING WITH THE
FACT HE DEFEATED DONALD TRUMP AT
A VERY FRAUGHT TIME IN OUR
HISTORY.
BUT THE OTHER THINGS THAT I
MENTIONED, BUT THIS ISN'T LIKE
OTHER PRESIDENTS.
BARACK OBAMA WAS AT 38% IN THE
SUMMER OF 2011.
BUT HE ALSO WAS 30 YEARS
YOUNGER.
AND THAT DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
AND PEOPLE WILL CONSIDER THAT,
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HE
HAS TO EVALUATE AS HE DECIDES
WHETHER HE'S ACTUALLY GOING TO
GO FORWARD AND RUN AGAIN.
>> BUT IT DOES SOUND LIKE YOU'RE
SUGGESTING -- I MEAN, I'M
PUTTING WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH, BUT
YOU'RE SUGGESTING, HEY,
PRESIDENT BIDEN, HAVING A
SUCCESSFUL ONE TERM WITH THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND GETTING
DONALD TRUMP OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE IS A NICE LEGACY.
>> IT IS A NICE LEGACY.
LOOK, NO ONE SHOULD TELL HIM
WHAT TO DO, AND IF HE DECIDES TO
RUN, HE'LL BE THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE.
THE IDEA THERE WILL BE A
SUCCESSFUL PRIMARY CHALLENGER,
EVEN A SERIOUS ONE Y THINK IS
FANTASY.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER IT'S
WISE.
AND WHETHER THAT'S WHAT HE FEELS
IS BEST FOR THE COUNTRY, FOR
HIM.
HE MAY FEEL HE'S THE ONLY GUY
WHO CAN BEAT DONALD TRUMP.
I'M NOT SURE THAT DONALD TRUMP